tout là-haut au coeur de la montagne
la vie est calme et paisible pas tout le
temps je m'attelle à elle dit en mal la
petite avec toi comment tu t'appelles
peppers tu es bien montrer comment tu
fais c'est bon une petite fille au grand
coeur d'un beau jaune et celles qui
étaient à la recherche d'une vraie
maison t'as lui grand père lui a dit
que dirais-tu d'aller vivre dans une
grande et belle maison
je m'appelle clara où nous utilisons
découvert dans cette maison la fillette
qui nous a été confiée est une petite
sauvageonne totalement inculte
le pays d'où tu viens c'est très
différent d'ici j'imagine tard
revivez cette aventure unique je n'ai
jamais vu clara aussi heureuse de toute
sa vie comme si c'était la première fois
heidi au cinéma le 10 février